year ago las vegas looked a lot
different businesses around the valley
forced to shut down this week businesses
opened up to 50 percent capacity joe
mohler live in downtown las vegas where
people
are actively celebrating the st
patrick's day holiday joe
yeah brian a lot of people out here well
let me tell you people we talked to
earlier
employees who work down here they say
they're excited to welcome a lot more
people
out to the restaurant so they can serve
them just in time for this holiday take
a live look here on the fremont street
experience there's
a lot of crowds here a lot of people
wearing green ready to celebrate
many enjoying the bars and restaurants
but what a difference a year makes
take a look at this video from one year
ago as the virus became a reality
businesses
were forced to close some even boarding
up doors and windows
downtown las vegas and fremont street
looked like a ghost town
this is video shot from our aviator
drone businesses laid off employees and
people scrambled to get unemployment
benefits
throughout the past year some places
reopened with limited capacities but
this week they were given the green
light to have 50 percent
i spoke to bianca sapida who works at la
comida kitchen
here in downtown she says she is happy
to be back at work
it was closed for about a year so we're
actually finally reopened
as of about three weeks ago so we've
been very happy so far
all the business is reopening to fifty
percent i think it's very exciting i
think there's lots of money to make so
i think that's exciting
now cepeda says they are glad to offer
some specials for st
patrick say to entice people to safely
come out now i also spoke to a worker
here in downtown las vegas now back out
here live take another look at fremont
street we spoke to
a number of employees at a couple
locations here at pizza shop just down
the street
the worker there says he's excited to
have people back here in downtown las
vegas at the 50
capacity he's noticing more people
wearing their mask and taking
precautions and he hopes it stays that
way
so businesses won't have to close again
until we can eventually get to that 100
percent capacity reporting live here in
downtown las vegas joe mullen eight news
now
we haven't seen partiers for quite a
while thanks joe